president biden held a news conference
in rome today after the g20 summit
wrapped up he took quite a few reporter
questions and covered a range of topics
from global minimum corporate tax to
various climate change initiatives peter
ducey is in rome with a recap of the
president's comments peter
john the president only took five
questions unfortunately we were not on
the list that staff handed him but i
caught him on the way to the motorcade
to ask about new reporting in the wall
street journal about possible possible
cash payments to migrants who were
separated from family members during the
last administration
president is it true that we're going to
give 450 000 to border crossers
who were separated
it looked like he heard me no answer and
it's possible he's just not familiar
with these reports the president is
celebrating taking one big step towards
one big tax hike elaborating on why he
and his foreign counterparts all agreed
to go back home and push for a global
minimum tax of 15 percent right now it's
zero percent not high enough for the
traveling president
instead of nations competing against one
another track investments
by bottoming out corporate tax rates
this set a minimum floor of 15 percent
to ensure that giant corporations begin
to pay their fair share no matter where
they're headquartered instead of hiding
hiding profits overseas
the president admitted today the g20
countries who came here to italy
representing 80 percent of the world's
gdp didn't go as far as they could have
in combating climate change because they
can't get two of the biggest polluters
on the board since they didn't want to
come
this appointment relates to the fact
that russia and
and
and
including
not only russia but china basically
didn't show up in terms of any
commitments to deal with climate change
and there's a reason why people should
be disappointed in that
i i found it disappointing myself
so the president is going to try harder
at a climate focused summit for the next
two days in scotland that is a wrap from
rome and the president is doing all this
without his press secretary we just
found out in the last few minutes jenn
saki has tested positive for coven 19.
she says she has not been in close
contact with the president since last
tuesday and they were outdoors masked
then john
better luck next time getting your
questions answered peter ducey from rome
thank you
still to come the migrant caravan
rolling toward texas hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else